Music
Pewdiepie
Pewdiepie was a drug addict
This was a fan fiction
Is that what you said?
It's an animation series
They made a whole animation?
Yes, someone animated this
Each episode is 5 minutes long
My first one was Apple.exe
I watched that one
Whoa, what is happening?
Where is the layer?
It's not on YouTube, is it? Because the Apple.exe I'm seeing is on YouTube
Oh, Apple.exe, it only has 100,000 views
Oh, it might have been removed, I think
I think a lot of those videos were removed, yeah
Oh, .mov, I'm so sorry
Apple.mov
There we go
Let me watch this piece of history here
First I have to get through a Grammarly ad
Ha!
I hate how YouTube forces you to
watch ads now
It's a 42 second ad and it's unskippable
Brother
Cupcakes where Pinkie Pie was like a serial killer
I watched um
I watched Happy Tree Friends as a kid
I watched it in elementary and I was scarred
That was my awakening of messed up stuff
Yeah
Why did they give Applejack a male voice?
No, a lot of them are, but not all of them
Is this some feederism kink?
Is she gonna get inflated?
I don't remember, it's been a hot
second since I watched this
Can I show it or is it gonna be really bad?
It's gonna be pretty bad Okay, I won't show it
You're probably gonna get claimed
They changed Fluttershy's voice so badly
Oh my god
Fluttershy is my favorite in that series
She used to scare me, but now I'm like
Yes girl, hang those heads on your wall
Go off queen
What the fuck
That is indeed the appropriate reaction
Stay out of my shit
What
I love the confusion, which part are you at?
I'm at the part where the sound of her eating apples is getting
looped in the background while she's staring at a void of
apples coming towards her
I see
And her head is turning into an apple
Oh
Yes, eye shadow
Oh she's just having a seizure, okay
That's the most tame reaction to someone having a seizure
No big deal guys
She went into an apple induced seizure
Oh girl, she eats the apple, she puked out again
Gross
Okay, it's not that bad
Oh that one's the most tame one out of them
Oh really? Should I look at the
Pinkie Pie what?
Someone said
Pinkie Pie turned into a serial killer
That one is cupcakes
That's another
My little pony fan animation
You should definitely watch it, it's definitely a part of the
experience
I'm making my pony a hoe right now
Cupcakes HD, is that it?
I think so
It's definitely a reupload
Yeah
Okay, I'll watch it
Wait they
They even have the opening credits too
Oh it's a song
Oh dude
This is totally going to trick kids
Yes
That's why it's very controversial, that's why it's not food
Cause it looks exactly like the show
Is this an original song
or is this
The song used in this video is ready to die by Andrew W.K.
Is that the song they use? Okay
Oh she's got heads on her wall
You better get ready to die
There's so many different brushes
Right they have so many different brushes but like no deform
tool
What did I want to do?
What was I doing?
You were turning your pony into a hoe
Oh yes
Thank you for reminding me
Every good hoe has a piercing
It's not that bad
Yeah
Imagine watching that kid
As a kid yeah, if you thought it was like a real
My little pony thing
And you get this instead, I guess yeah it's pretty traumatizing
Holy fuck
How is this allowed on YouTube? Don't they not allow excessive gore?
Oh yeah that's back in the day when
They didn't have that much restrictions and everything
Ew
What the hell
The golden era
Do you guys miss this era of YouTube when it was allowed to post gore of
Pinkie Pie making cupcakes with
Rainbow Dash's intestines
You know what I do agree
It was pretty good era
Back in the day when
You would watch an anime on YouTube and it was part one of 26
Yeah I liked that
I watched the entirety of Powerpuff Girls Z
On YouTube
I watched Akame Godkill and
Is it wrong to pick up girls in a dungeon on YouTube?
Yay wow that came out
How to pick up girls in a dungeon came out that long ago?
I think so let me see
Dude why does that feel so recent to me
That's crazy
Is it wrong to pick up girls in a dungeon?
Someone educated me
In another one called Rainbow Factory
They were originally fan fictions that turned into
Animations
It was released in 2015
Holy shit
That doesn't sound long enough ago
It does not dude
Especially 2019
That sounds so recent
That was so so so long ago
It was
It wasn't long ago but yeah it was long
Long enough ago to where you were surprised when you realized how long ago it was made
Yeah
Can I help you color?
I'll do the flat colors
I won't do any of your shading
Are you doing shading?
Not for the hair
I have to do it on a different layer
You better get ready to die
I'll get your tail
Thank you
I like how you have sparkles and stuff
Damn
That's probably how I should have done the crystal pony
With sparkles more than
Random blocks of rectangles
Triangles
But that's how they did in the show
That's how they draw their crystal ponies in the show
It's just random rectangles of paler colors and darker colors
It's lower accurate
I got a lower accurate crystal pony
Yes sir
What do you mean that's over a decade ago
I guess that makes sense
2015 is not 11 years ago
9 years ago
Yeah
I colored in your tail
Uh oh
Does someone remember happy tree friends?
I don't remember much of it
I remember seeing a lot of
Interesting problematic fan art of happy tree friends
I remember that
And I remember liking the fan art
I remember when I
I did watch the show
I was in the other girl
I thought I could handle my gore and my horror
And everything as a kid
This is nothing to me
It was like memory of watching this one episode
And it was so gory that I had to turn it off
I would get scared too
But I was the same way
I was like I can handle this
I'm a big girl
I thought this was a kids show
I didn't expect it to be so gory
We need more shows like happy tree friends nowadays
Everything is like watered down baby garbage
Even in terms of adult shows
That's true we don't have enough gory stuff like this anymore
You got stuff like Belma these days
Like
I never watched Belma
But I remember the controversy with Belma
Oh what controversy
The fact that it's a shit show
The controversial existence of Belma
What about metal
What
People were just
I think they were just mad because it was a bad show
And they took a really good
Children's show that a lot of people cared about
And they kind of just made a bad one out of it
Yeah makes sense
And that's why people were mad at it
Yeah
We got terrifier I don't know that one
It was an insult to the original
For sure
But like just don't watch it and then you won't be insulted
I didn't watch the show
Per se I watched other people watch it
I watched all of this channel called Spilling the Milk
And they just watched a bunch of cartoons
And they spliced their funniest moments together
Are you done
We're both done
Okay here's our pony OCs
We have Ruby Glitter
She looks very rock and roll
Very edgy
I'm glad
And here's Luna Blossom who is not in any way related to the moon
But she is blossoming out those pumpkin leaves
Yes
They look like such a beautiful lesbian couple
They could be
It's the stereotypical
Butch and the more feminine one
The cool girl and the cute girl
If you want to save it you can just do a CTRL S
And it will save the drawing
Ah how easy
And it saves the drawing
I'm going to end it here
But thank you for drawing with me
And talking about my little pony
Of course thank you for indulging in my
Wanting to do this
I wanted to do it too
I needed to draw an updated pony sona so here it is
Luna Blossom the Crystal Pony
I'll see you guys tomorrow with
The Don't Starve collab with IC
Would you like to lurk? Not lurk
Raid the same person
Yeah you're streaming on YouTube right?
Yeah I don't think I can raid, can I? Cause I thought you have to add
Each other and then you have to consent for other people to raid you
I thought that's how that worked
Can you, are you able to raid Shibi?
I will try
You go to a YouTube studio
And you go to content
And then totomate
Okay okay
Oh yeah we're too learning Japanese
How's that going? Oh was I
I had classes when I was in university but I haven't done anymore after
After those classes
I was gonna test your new homegirl Josie
Anyways I am in
Go to the live section in your content category
And then
And then press the pencil button
And then customization and then scroll down to where it says redirect
And then search videos from other channels
And then you have to be subscribed though
I think I am
It's not immediate if I click it
It's only after you end the stream
Oh my god that's so much better than Twitch
You don't have to press an extra button or anything
It'll redirect people
We can have more MLP related streams I guess
Maybe one day we can do a watch along
Yeah
You all better join
And ditch that poor poor way of thinking
No you're gonna sit here and watch us
Be happy
Oh my god
We're gonna strap you down
We're gonna strap you down and make you watch
Tear open your eyelids hold it up with a
matchstick or whatever
Okay I'll see you tomorrow
Bye bye
Bye
Thanks for watching